let's go to our next caller from the
nine one five area code caller from nine
one five introduce yourself say hello
tell us who you are where you're calling
from and I'd love to hear your question
uh hi can you hear me
yeah we can hear you fine awesome hi
David my name is Miguel and I'm from
Texas I wanted to ask this is concerning
the elections here in Texas specifically
like the Senate race you know between
bateau Rorick and Ted Cruz I don't know
if you've been following that or not
solutely okay awesome do you think by
any means possible Beto or the Democrats
here in Texas have any chance to pull
off a win and like historically red
Texas or do you think Ted Cruz is just
gonna take it in the wind no I I don't
believe Miguel in irrational optimism or
irrational pessimism so what's the
reality the reality is that Ted Cruz is
the incumbent there's big power with
incumbency at the same time Beto
O'Rourke has been doing some really
great fundraising he's also depending on
which poll you look at not that far
behind I think that yeah you know I'm
not gonna tell you that better or work
has this thing in the bag and I'm not
gonna tell you that he has no chance
it's a very uphill battle especially as
you close in on Election Day the thing
about the power of incumbency a lot of
people think it's just money right but
there's another element to it which is
when you have an incumbent there will be
people who are not necessarily figuring
in as strong supporters of Ted Cruz per
se who will show up on Election Day and
either number one vote incumbent or
number two vote for the party that has
the dominant political registration in
Texas which is the Republican Party so
there are people who are going to show
up on election day without really having
given too much thought if you polled
them they wouldn't say I'm like a strong
Ted Cruz supporter or I'm a strong
better or work supporter but they'll
either vote for whoever's the Republican
or whoever's already there if they think
that things have been going pretty well
and in both cases it's Ted Cruz so I
think that this it
this is worth putting time and money
into if you're the Democrats because the
significance of defeating Ted Cruz would
just be massive is it likely no it's not
likely but it's a possible race and I
think it's a good one to fight alright
yeah it sounds pretty interesting
I am hopeful and certain that Beto might
win I do like a lot of his the work that
he's done yeah for a while now but yeah
you kind of have to have that sort of
sense of realism so yeah I don't think
anybody really wins by pretending like
he's got it or pretending like he's out
you know
all right Miguel thank you I know you'll
be voting that's for sure and that's
everybody should vote that's a very very
good thing